every position
it almost looks like they got their
roster from the olympic relay team and
threw them all on the football field not
to say they can't run routes and catch
either because they can do that so
they're they're a special group and and
you can see why they're there
robert salah the 49ers defensive
coordinator talking about the chiefs
receivers and you know the problem is
the 49ers defense is very well
constructed to cover you
for a short period of time the longer
you have to run around the harder it's
going to be for that secondary to keep
track of tyree kill travis kelsey
sammy watkins mikhole hardman throw
demarcus robinson into there as well and
patrick mahomes has that ability to
extend the play that's why the 49ers
rely on the front four to get to the guy
and force him to throw before they have
a chance to run around and get open and
these guys we've seen it time and again
they know how to run around and get open
and patrick mahomes knows how to buy
time with his feet and find that guy who
is wide open and get him the football
yeah it's the combo of patreon homes
being able to slide in the pocket and
the chiefs really too
somehow they have found a way to get
every fast guy in his in football on one
roster because it feels like every time
you watch them there's a new guy running
down the field and and no one can keep
up with him and oh yeah you forgot
travis kelsey underneath all of that so
i it's going to be very interesting what
happens and more than anything mike the
interesting matchup is whoever richard
sherman's guarding because the 49ers
have been great this year for a lot of
reasons but one of the biggest reasons
is richard sherman has been great and
he's great in coverage and you basically
can say he's got his guy and he's not
going to get beat well guess what the
one type of receiver that richard
sherman does struggle with historically
is basically every receiver on the
chiefs and tyree kill most importantly
is a is like the uh you know almost
almost like a caricature of every
receiver that richard sherman struggles
with he's fast he he won't get you know
he can get around richard sherman he's
not gonna let richard sherman body him
once he's by him he's gone richard
sherman historically has always done
well with bigger receivers who try to
use their body because he's a big guy
himself so having tyreek hill having me
cole harbin having sammy watkins having
some of these guys that are going to
give him problems
is going to be a problem for the 49ers
as a whole because they have been able
to all year long
count on richard sherman being that guy
where he can basically eliminate their
number one weapon without any issues and
having that maybe be iffy
it changes the entire damn dynamic of
what the 49ers are doing on defense
i just want the record to be clear that
these are all comments that come came
from dan big cat cats not me
lest i be dubbed a hater for calling
into question the skills and abilities
of richard sherman who has been great
this year he has been and he takes fuel
and motivation from any actual or
perceived slight he had derailed revis
calling him out for not being a true
man-to-man corner he's a zone guy but
you're right look he's he's in his 30s
he's a big guy
he's going to have a hard time with
tyree kill if they run tyree kill into
his zone or through his zone and past
him like we saw last week one of the
bright spots for the packers devonta
adams a little too little and a little
too late running past richard sherman
for a 60-yard gain so you know it's part
of what they're gonna have to construct
and they're gonna have to get the ball
out fast they're gonna have to get after
patrick mahomes they're gonna have to
get him off of his spot and they're
gonna have to pressure him to throw the
ball before those guys get wide open
that's the key and that front four is as
good if not better than any in the nfl
that's gonna be the challenge putting
enough pressure on patrick mahomes to
make him throw the ball before those
receivers find that opening and are wide
open in the secondary yeah it's
interesting because the 49ers defense
has been very good all year and i think
they do have the the makeup to to defend
a team like the chiefs because like you
said anytime you get pressure with four
everything else gets easier the thing
with the chiefs though
is you can guard one of them you can
guard travis kelsey you can guard tyree
kill you can't guard all of them and
that's where they become a nightmare
match-up because
you know a lot of times when you look at
a team in the super bowl it's like all
right if we can eliminate this guy
we have a chance the chiefs have four of
these guys so they can beat you so many
different ways and oh yeah patrick
mahomes is the one throwing the ball it
becomes a nightmare matchup and i i have
to imagine
robert sala has not had a lot of sleep
this week or next week
and if you're gonna put a spy on patrick
mahomes in anticipation of him running
the ball it can't be rashawn evans who
fell for the okey doke head fake it's
got to be a guy with the athleticism to
track patrick holmes down and not let
him get past the second level of the
defense more pfc libraries
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports